The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So to all of our
guests, thank you for coming.
This is the final presentations
for CMS.611 crossed listed
as 6.073 the Creating
Video Games class.
In this class, we
have 40 students,
learning how to make games and
learning about the production
process of making games.
So a lot of the things we're
talking about in class,
a little bit about
design, but often also
about how do you
communicate as a team.
How do you get work done
on time and on schedule,
as I overheard a lot of things
happening this last week.
Every year, we choose a
client to make games for.
This year, we were very blessed
to have the Red Cross/Red
Crescent Climate
Centre, in Pablo Suarez.
As our common
client, he presented
a number of different games,
ideas, and topics ideas
to the class.
The class formed teams about
those for the final projects.
And that's what we're
going to be seeing today.
Our order of presentations
are going to be over here.
So we're going to have
three presentations.
Each presentation is about
20 minutes plus another 10
for Q&A and then
just tech switches.
We'll have the intermission
after Heatwaves is finished.
And then we've got two more.
Cholera, I did not write down
the full name for your game.
Your team, Lauren.
What is the full
name for your game?
LAUREN: Cholera Control.
PROFESSOR: Cholera Control.
Make a note of that.
So they and [INAUDIBLE]
will be last.
I also wanted to mention
to all the students
here, if you're
interested in continuing
your education on game
development, as you can see,
spring is loaded
with game courses.
CMS.301, which is taught
by Sara and Michael
in the back-- hi, Michael.
MICHAEL: Hi.
PROFESSOR: It is an introduction
to game design methods.
In particular, it's unpacking
the idea of prototyping
[INAUDIBLE] for digital games.
And the lessons
learned there can
be applied to pretty much
any kind of designer,
but they're focusing
on game design methods.
CMS.608, Phillip and I teach,
is board game and card game
design.
It's structured, actually,
very similar to this class
with a few small projects and
then a final project at the end
that you spend about
half the semester on.
And those, of course,
are non-digital games, so
board games, card games.
We've had people do live
action RPGs and tabletop
RPGs, role-playing
games for that class.
The next two courses,
CMS.610, Art, Science,
and Business Video Games, and
CMS.617, Advanced Game Studio,
also built on the team building
aspect but not as harshly
as we do.
You won't be in
eight-person teams,
unless you really want to.
Teams tend to be about four to
five people for those classes,
and actually as low as
three in some cases for 617.
Right now in the catalog,
they both look like they're
being taught on Thursday.
We are trying to
move 617 to Tuesday.
So I'll send out an
announcement about that.
And then lastly, if you liked
creating the specific games
you made in class this
semester, these kind
of educational
games, or do you want
to know more about how
games are used in education,
how to make games for education
and how to simulations
in particular for
education, CMS.590
cross-listed I think-- I
didn't look up the number--
but my memory said
11.129 is Computer Games
and Simulation for Investigation
and Education, tion.
That is taught-- last year, it
was taught by Scot Osterweil
and Jason Haas with Eric Klopfer
is the faculty on that course.
A really great course,
I highly recommend it.
You can look up
the syllabus in OCW
if you want to
know more about it.
And with that, we are
going to start with Snap.
TEJ CHAJED: All
right, hi, everybody.
I'm Tej, and I'm
from the Snap team.
We're going to start off
with a demo of our game.
So the way our
game works is it's
called Snap and
everybody participates
from their own computer.
We'll give you a
topic, and then you'll
enter words related
to that topic.
And whenever you get the
same word as somebody else,
you'll get a point.
So it's pretty simple.
So we'll invite you to
join us at snapgame.org.
We'll be showing the
moderator interface.
So normally, you
wouldn't be seeing this.
The moderator would
do it on their own.
But we'd like to
show this, because it
is a part of our game.
All right, and the topic we'll
be doing today, to mix it up
from last time, is video games.
And we'll run the game for
about two minutes this time.
All right, so I have no
idea how long it's been.
But I'm going to
give a countdown,
and I'm going to stop the game.
10, 9, 8, 7, 6, 5, 4, 3, 2, 1.
And that's a game.
Congratulations, Julia,
and Kevin in second place.
This is what you guys invented.
Thank you, guys,
for playing Snap.
That was [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: Luigi [? book. ?]
AUDIENCE: What was that?
AUDIENCE: Luigi.
TEJ CHAJED: All right,
so as you can see,
this gives you an idea of
what you were thinking about,
what you think about when you
think video games, which not
surprisingly right now is Snap.
And with that,
we've given a feel
for the moderator interface.
And hopefully, you got a
chance to play the game
and see what the player sees.
And we'll start
the presentation.
So this game was made
for the Red Cross.
Pablo actually helped
co-develop this game.
And he presented it to
us as a face-to-face game
that they play at conferences.
He provided feedback
and guidance.
And in our project, in
particular, the client
was extremely helpful in giving
us an idea of what they wanted
and also helping us run the
game in their actual settings.
So we were able to see what
this looks like with the players
that we expect to play with.
For our organization
of our project,
we split up into backend
and frontend teams.
The backend worked
on both the server
and also the moderator interface
you saw here and to word cloud,
for example.
This split was challenging
for new features,
especially, because
features would
be interdependent or
frontend couldn't do anything
until there was a backend.
And there was a
communication gap throughout.
When we needed to
add a new feature,
the API between the
backend and frontend
wasn't necessarily
well-documented.
But overall, we think that
it led to simpler management
within the teams.
We didn't have a lot of
organization within each team.
There wasn't a lot of
explicit organization.
But it did help to know
that a smaller set of people
would be working on the
frontend or the backend
at any given time.
In the future, I think we would
have gone even more specific
in our roles.
Like a few roles that we thought
would have been important
include a UI designer.
This would have made sure that
UI design saw some first class
love from the beginning
and would have made sure
that we actually focused
on UI from the beginning.
It also would have helped to
have somebody communicating
between the teams.
This person may have
done some documentation
or may have simply
just made sure
that the frontend knew what
the backend was working on
and the backend knew
what the frontend needed,
so we could prioritize
well between the teams.
It also would have
helped to have somebody
dedicated to paperwork.
This would have helped both
in submitting class paperwork
and also just doing the
documentation that we needed,
both for ourselves
and the class.
And finally, somebody
working on game design
would have helped us develop
more iterations early on
and think more about
the game aspects that
go beyond what we already
knew the game would
look like based on
the game of Snap
we played from the clients.
As far as technology
for our organization,
we used Asana to
organize our tasks.
Asana worked really well for us.
In particular, it let us split
the task lists for the frontend
and backend.
This was useful, because
generally, the frontend
didn't need to touch the
backend tasks and vice versa.
But on the other hand,
we had a hard time
encoding task dependencies.
This was particularly a
problem for a feature that
crossed both the
backend and frontend,
where some API was
needed on the backend
and then was also
needed on the frontend.
And you couldn't do
one without the other.
We also had trouble
with task creation.
And this basically meant that
people didn't create tasks.
And part of this was that we
didn't have a specific role
for creating the tasks.
And so, because of the
diffusion of responsibility,
nobody would go through
and list out everything
that needed to be done.
To improve that in
the future, we'd
like to get people
more invested.
Part of this was that people
had a lot of other classes.
And it would have helped if
people both explicitly said
how much they were going
to commit to the class
and also we made it
easier for people
to contribute with the
small amount of time
that they had available.
SABRINA DRAMMIS: So
for communication,
our group used an
instant messaging
application called Slack.
And this was really
great for us,
because it allowed
us to separate
into different channels.
As you see here, we have
frontend and backend
as two different channels and
then a general channel where
everyone can communicate.
And this let the frontend
people work on their thing
separately from the
backend, not needing to know
exactly what was going on.
But they could go look, if
they needed to reference
some conversation there.
The bad part about this was that
people weren't always online
and responsive right away.
And I think we could of
made this not a problem,
if we required everyone
in our project to download
the mobile application.
That way, they would get
a notification immediately
when they were mentioned.
And they would be more
likely to respond quicker.
TEJ CHAJED: On the
backend, generally things
went really well.
Our technology, in particular,
worked really well for us.
We used node.js for the
server, and socket.io
for two-way communication
with the browser,
and Heroku to do deployment.
We were explicitly forbidden
from using networking
in this class, which we
violated from the beginning.
But I think that our experience
with networking and all three
of these technologies really
helped make that possible.
We already knew how to use them.
And that helped us
both debug issues
and understand what
we were working with.
On the other hand,
the backend it seemed
had too much manpower.
This manifested itself as
a problem on the frontend,
where sometimes we felt like
we didn't have enough people.
We could have had fewer people
working on the backend, which
would have made sure that it
was a small unified code base,
and we could quickly finalize
the backend and just move on.
We actually deployed
the application,
and the client has been
using what we showed.
This is actually a
quite early deployment
on November 18 in Berlin
with some students there.
And you can see the words
that they generated.
Here are some other deployments.
One of the things that made this
class-- what was challenging
for us is that we had to
manage both client expectations
and the course expectations.
So because they were
asking us to do these runs,
it seemed important to
us to support these runs.
And it was hard to balance doing
this and also during the tasks
that the course required of
us and needed for us to do.
SABRINA DRAMMIS: So
I'm going to talk
a little bit about our frontend
design and that process.
So initially, when we
started the project,
we had this idea that people
would be represented as a car
and they would be
racing other players.
So we thought it
would be a great idea
to use Phaser, which is a
sprite-based game framework.
But as you see here, we didn't
go through with the car idea.
And we had no sprites.
But we still used Phaser to
make this, our first design
iteration.
And we realized we didn't
really want that type of look
for our game.
We needed something more
professional and more abstract
that could be used in any
sort of setting that Pablo,
our client, may use it.
So we completely
scrapped Phaser.
And we redid our
frontend design,
deciding to just use
Bootstrap and CoffeeScript.
And this was our second design.
As you can see here, it's just
very typical Bootstrap styling,
if you've ever used
Bootstrap before.
So we tried to add a
little bit of flavor.
And we also needed a better
way to kind of represent
how the game is
progressing to the player.
We currently had no idea
for that in this design.
So then we came up
with the final design
that you guys played,
our theme of having blue.
And then we created this
visualization to the right,
where each player is
represented by a dot.
And snaps are represented by
lines being drawn to dots.
And your height
is representative
of your score in relation
to all the other players.
So how we kind of got to
this final visualization idea
was an interesting process.
First, we thought it'd
be really cool to have
a word cloud on the frontend,
as well as the back end.
But a player would only
be able to see the words
that they had submitted.
All the other words
would be blurred out.
But this didn't really
convey to the player
where they were in relation
to all the other players.
So there wasn't any
sort of competitiveness.
So we came up with this
idea of having a race line,
where all the players
would be on the line
and the height would represent
their score and their position.
And then we thought, well, we
can put these both together.
But we investigated
the word cloud.
And we realized it'd be
extremely difficult to blur out
these words.
And it wasn't really going to
be the best use of our time.
So then we came
up with this idea
of using dots to
represent players.
And we thought it'd be cool
if the size of your dot
represented your score.
But the use case
for our application
could involve 100
players or even more.
So a lot of growing large dots
could really clutter our UI,
so we needed to rethink this.
And this is when we finally
ended up deciding on height
representing score.
So I think we had really
good UI designers.
And they were really quick.
Once we thought
of ideas, we were
quick being able
to implement it.
But the bad part was that we
were really late in coming up
with design decisions.
We didn't start
thinking about how
we wanted to convey
the game to the player
and how we wanted to make the
player feel about the game
until really late
in the project.
We focused more on what
the client needed as far
as mechanics and not really
what the player was getting out
of the game.
So in the future,
definitely we need
to think about design
right from the get-go.
And we need to start prototyping
all the ideas that we have
and testing them
out more thoroughly.
TEJ CHAJED: So in summary,
the high points of our project
are that we did make
the client happy.
And they've been using our
application and the game.
And they really like the game.
We're glad that
we focused on fun.
The game has been
fun throughout.
And players seem
to really enjoy it.
And I think maybe this is just
because of the core concept.
And we're glad that, even though
this is an educational game,
it is intended for purposes
honestly of data collection,
people really enjoy playing it.
Unfortunately, we had
slow design iteration.
This prevented us from
really fully realizing
all the ideas that we had
and figuring out which
one would be best for players.
In the future, we'd like
to get people more invested
to try to solve these
issues and make sure
that we best use
our time and create
the best product possible.
And with that, we'll
take questions.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] Is there
a maximum number of players?
TEJ CHAJED: We did
some stress tests
to see how much the backend
on Heroku could support.
And that seemed to work OK
up to 150 players or teams.
We are not really sure
what the frontend might
look like at 150 real players.
That might be actually
the limiting factor.
AUDIENCE: Is that
150 people playing
the same session or in the
multiple sessions 150 people?
TEJ CHAJED: We currently don't
support multiple sessions.
This is actually a request that
the client repeatedly gave us.
But we thought that it
was just much simpler
to avoid that for now, because
it wasn't strictly necessary.
Most likely, the
load on the backend
would be the same,
whether they were
split into multiple sessions.
But this is a solvable problem
by getting a beefier backend.
AUDIENCE: I see.
But right now, the backend
supports 150 people
logged in simultaneously.
TEJ CHAJED: About 150.
We can obviously pay money
to get better servers
and then run with many more.
AUDIENCE: OK.
TEJ CHAJED: Any questions
from the audience?
AUDIENCE: So you got
some feedback from Pablo
specifically from the
moderator point of view.
And I'm wondering whether you
got any indication about what
the players felt outside of
this class plus your [INAUDIBLE]
TEJ CHAJED: Sure, I think we
can both talk about our focus
tests, where we played with
players outside this class.
SABRINA DRAMMIS: Yeah, so
one of the main things,
I played with maybe a
group of at most 10 people.
And they knew each
other, so they
wanted to know who they
were snapping with.
And they wanted to see
the names of all the dots,
so they could know
who they were beating
or who they needed
to catch up to.
But this would be unreasonable
in a large environment,
especially when all the
people at the conference
probably don't know each other.
But I think that would be
a really cool thing to do,
if we continued working
on this in the future.
TEJ CHAJED: And I also
ran a similar test
with people that
knew each other.
And they actually used it
as part of their strategy.
They knew what
other players would
be submitting for that topic.
And they could use that
to their advantage.
So, for example, we did a
topic of systems papers.
And we had a professor
in the group,
so his paper showed up a bunch.
And I would echo what Sabrina
said, that players really
wanted more feedback
around the actual players
in the game, which we
specifically didn't do,
because the client didn't care.
And in conferences, people
don't generally know each other.
But I think that
if we were to use
this as a more popular game,
then definitely focusing
on players and getting
more feedback, especially
after the game is over.
People wanted to know who
they were snapping with.
They wanted to see that graph,
all those lines overlaid,
so they could see who they
were snapping with most often.
AUDIENCE: Does the team
have any plans for this game
after this class?
I was wondering if you've
ever had discussions yet.
TEJ CHAJED: I think we
haven't discussed that yet.
But I think definitely
we're interested in it.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
TEJ CHAJED: Thank you.
MATT: Hello.
We are Hello waves.
We're game about
forecasting, specifically
this idea called forecast-based
financing of using forecast
to make decisions about
possible disasters in the future
and how to prepare for them.
We would actually like to start
with a playthrough of our game.
So if anybody would like to
be a volunteer to try it out.
AUDIENCE: A guest from
not our class, if one
could please come down, Andrew.
AUDIENCE: Thank you
for volunteering.
ANDREW: Hi, I'm Andrew.
AUDIENCE: Well, do
you need a chair?
AUDIENCE: Here's one.
MATT: I'm not quite sure how
to make that full screen.
But anyways, this is our game.
I'd recommend looking
at the instructions
first and reading through them.
Thanks.
And we'll keep the
description minimal
as you read through it just
to sort of show the player's
initial reaction to it.
ANDREW: Now, this
is real, correct?
NORMAN: You're signed on?
MATT: Oh, is it?
Oh.
NORMAN: Yeah, right.
OK, sorry.
Music.
MATT: Yeah, start up again.
So as you can see, our
game, as I said before,
you control some toys
on a day at the beach.
And so by dragging and dropping
them between the castles,
you'll see that their
statuses change and say
that they want to move
on their next turn,
or that they want
to be collecting--
or that they're going to be
collecting candy, or anything
like that.
And the game is turned based.
So all the actions will
resolve on the next turn.
ANDREW: Am I rating this race?
MATT: Yeah.
NORMAN: You can also access the
help through the lower right
corner as well.
MATT: And so when you
go to the next turn,
you'll see all the toys move
as specified by the status
bubble above their heads.
ANDREW: So I go to the next
turn, or do I get a next turn?
MATT: But unfortunately,
you'll find
that when toys have been
evacuated, they're unhappy
and need candy to survive,
so they'll all take damage.
ANDREW: They don't
want you to evacuate.
MATT: You can try returning
them to their homes.
NORMAN: And so you'll
see that on this turn
instead, now they have
their statuses set
to gathering candy, except for
the dump truck, who is still
evacuated.
ANDREW: Got you, OK.
But he needs to be evacuated.
NORMAN: Exactly.
And so the idea is that as
a player plays through it,
they get better at understanding
how to use the forecast
to make decisions
about the future,
both in terms of how much candy
that they need to have stocked
up in order to weather
out the rising tides
and also in terms
of when they're
going to need to move
their workers out
of-- their toys out of the
areas that are in danger.
ANDREW: They're going
to be really impacted.
MATT: I think you
have those two guys.
ANDREW: Oh, they're in there?
Is there a reminder
of where they started?
MATT: Yeah, it's on the castle.
It's actually blocked
out right now,
but toward the front of it.
But there's a little
shadow there, an imprint.
Because he ran out of candy
and then-- or actually, sorry,
because he went to a
place that was underwater,
he took too much damage and then
was swept away by the waves.
And so on the
forecast, you can see
that high water is coming
for quite a while, which
is going to be a
danger for the toys,
both in terms of possibly
getting swept away
and not having enough candy for
all the toys that you're going
to have to move out of the way.
ANDREW: [INAUDIBLE] this time.
NORMAN: Oh, he may
be out of luck.
MATT: Yeah.
And when you've lost two
toys, you lose the game.
ANDREW: OK.
MATT: Thank you for playing.
So that's Hello waves.
So in our game, we had a
few challenges to overcome.
The first was that
our game was based
on forecast-based financing,
which is a very abstract topic.
It's a pretty
understandable idea
of using information about
the future and ideas of risk
in order to decide where
to allocate resources.
But it's still a bit abstract.
And building a game around
it took a little bit of work.
It's useful to note
that it's different
than long-term planning.
It's not just thinking about
what will happen in the future,
building a dam to prevent
water or things like that.
And it's actually about
using the information
you have to make the
best decision for events
that may be upcoming in
the semi-near future.
We also wanted to avoid
making a game that
was overly preachy or
simplified, where it was clear
exactly how you're going to win.
And you could just
basically push
the forecast-based financing
button to win the game.
We wanted players to
actually think and understand
the concepts there,
instead of just coming up
with the buzzword of
forecast-based financing.
And finally, we
had the challenge
of actually communicating that
forecast to players in a way
that they would be
able to understand
and then make use of.
You could see in that game
that we had water levels
and it would show on the map.
And we found that players
were pretty good at using that
in order to make
decisions about what
was going to happen
in the future
and how to allocate
their resources.
The other big challenge
that we had in the beginning
was that our initial target
audience was policymakers.
Like for Snap, Pablo had come in
and pitched us this game idea.
And originally, he had
wanted us to build a game
for policymakers that
would help them understand
the benefits of
forecast-based financing
and, therefore, convince
them that they should develop
policies that would give
resources to plans based
on forecast-based financing.
So I would like to take
you through a couple
of our prototypes just to show
you the evolution and comment
sort of on our process.
Actually, to preface that,
we had a lot of prototypes,
because of our idea
was so abstract
and because we weren't sure
how to address our audience.
So we built a lot of
prototypes to start with.
We had ideas that ranged
across sort of levels of scope
of what you controlled, where
you controlled entire cities
or where you controlled
individual workers
and moved them around.
And then we would pull from
all these different kinds
of ideas what worked, what
didn't, what did people
understand, what confused them.
And from that, we got
a really good idea
of what concepts helped
people understand the idea
and brought them into this final
game that we ended up with.
So the project
started on October 15.
And this was our
first prototype.
It was a terminal-based
game, where
you had some kind of information
about a future rainfall.
And then you had to type in your
commands of how you controlled
different cities.
This, actually,
people found it fun.
But as you might expect, the
feedback wasn't very good.
And people didn't
quite understand
how to move forward with it.
It put a lot of
cognitive load on people.
So when we moved
forward, we tried
to give people more easily
understandable actions to use.
But the problem with this game
was that it was time based
and it updated every second.
And so there are so
numbers flying at people,
like even MIT students who play
tested it couldn't understand.
So we figured that
people like policymakers,
who didn't have much
experience with games,
really wouldn't be able to
understand the game at all.
So instead, we
went to turn based.
And that helped.
But at the same time, it's
tough to see on this projector,
but we have a forecast
underneath that says
how much rainfall is expected.
And again, that wasn't
understandable to people,
because they couldn't understand
what three inches of rainfall
meant for their city.
And they couldn't understand
how that contributed
to a possible disaster.
At this point, Pablo
actually came by the class
and played the game.
And then he told us
that he wasn't even sure
that he could get
policymakers to play the game,
because they may not
have enough time.
Instead, he wanted us to
switch to grade schoolers,
because we could
teach them something
about forecast-based financing
and help them understand
as they grew up.
And this was great
for us, because making
a game that was serious,
easy for somebody
who didn't have experience
with games to play, and also
fun and engaging was too
difficult for us actually.
So moving to grade
schoolers was awesome.
He also suggested that we try
to make the idea of rainfall
or water levels more visceral.
And that's when we came upon
this idea of the rising waters.
Whenever players looked
at this, they instantly
understood the
concept of the game.
The feedback might not be there.
The beautiful UI
might not be there.
But the idea of having
cities with workers in them
and a rising water level
coming towards them, everybody
understood that.
And it made it a lot
easier for players
to reason about the game.
From there, we added things
like nicer art, better feedback,
which you can't quite see
in the static picture, more
improvements to how
the forecast worked.
And eventually, we ended up
with our final version today.
NORMAN: So to talk a little bit
about our actual development
process, so our team was
structured into three
main subteams, production,
which was in charge
of managerial roles,
deliverables, and play testing,
and so there was a shared
responsibility there;
technical team,
which was in charge
of the bulk of the coding
work; and a user experience
team, which would be in charge
of assets, UI design, and UI
design.
We also initially
envisioned subteam leaders,
where we'd be kind of
communicating through them.
But we found the concept
kind of redundant.
And so we've worked pretty
much with like a flat structure
between the three teams.
So from the beginning,
we encouraged good coding
practice.
And so we used good
tools available to us.
One of these is Yeoman, which
is a JavaScript scaffolding
framework.
And this helped us out a
lot by basically automating
a lot of our JavaScript tasks
and making our code modular.
We also used Phaser
state machine,
which is this kind of badly
documented new feature
in the Phaser game engine,
which was the JavaScript game
engine that we used.
It's a bit badly documented.
But it did save us
a lot of headaches.
And once we figured that out,
that proved immensely helpful.
And we also used MVC, which is
a computer software engineering
term standing for
Model View Controller.
And again, by encouraging
these good coding practices,
we reduced dependencies and
made sure that our team was
productive.
In terms of communication,
we also, similar to Snap,
used Slack, which is kind of
like a modernized chatrooms.
It's very feature rich.
And so you can share files,
channels, and things like that.
And we also use the
idea of the Daily Scrum.
We implemented it in class.
And we would say what we
had done that class, what
we would be doing, and what we
wanted to do until next class.
And so now, the major
challenges that we
faced during the development
process though where
that our team members came
from very different backgrounds
and had very different
preferences about games.
Some of our team members are
very hardcore StarCraft players
and very good at RTS games,
while other members of our team
preferred like a more laid
back mobile game Fruit Ninja
kind of approach.
And so trying to mediate
those two viewpoints
and trying to create
a game that would
engage both types of
gamers was a challenge
that we had to overcome.
And so another big challenge
that we had in our development
process, as you saw
through our progression
through our
different prototypes,
was that our direction was not
very clear, until about halfway
through the project.
And so partially because we
had different ideas on what
the game should look like and
also partially because we had
such an abstract idea of
forecast-based financing
that even we didn't have that
good of a grasp on initially,
it took us a while
to really get settled
on what we wanted to build.
And so this really challenged
our development process
and made us have to build a
lot before we got something
that we liked.
And so eventually,
we did end up having
to cut some features
of like multiple levels
or like a guided
tutorial for the player.
We thought that this would
introduce too much new content
that would need to be play
tested, balanced, and tested
to ensure consistency with
the rest of our game, which
we viewed as taking
up too much time.
And we also cut the idea of
adding more individuality
to the workers or to
the toys that you saw,
other than different
graphics for each.
MATT: Some of the worst
things that we did on our team
is that we spent a
lot of time on work
that got thrown out entirely.
All the prototypes we did, they
were actually pretty useful,
because of the things we learned
about the concept and about
how people would play the game.
But we did spend a
lot of time on things
like art or nitty gritty
details that didn't really
need to be figured out and
that we could have put off
until later in the project.
We also kept the game direction
too vague for too long.
As Norman said, we spent
a lot of time with that.
And it probably ate up
too much of our time.
Although it helped
us learn, we could
have moved faster
in the beginning
to get to a solid idea.
Because once we got to a solid
idea of the rising waters,
our team started to
centralize around it
a lot better, because
we could actually
deal with something concrete.
While we were dealing
with the abstract ideas,
everybody was all over the
place and arguing about things
that didn't quite line up.
And the worst decision of
all that we started with
and that sort of made the
problem of going too vague
and all these
other things happen
is that we were
originally thinking,
how do we skin forecast
based financing as a game?
How do we take this
idea of using forecast
to make decisions and
then just gamify it,
which we eventually
realized wasn't fun
and didn't help us actually
come up with any ideas.
Instead when we
flipped it and started
talking about what game
could we create and use
forecast-based financing to
improve it and teach players
how to play the game and,
therefore, allow them to come
out of the game, having learned
about forecast-based financing,
the world sort of opened up.
Everything became a
lot more interesting.
And we found that we
started to move faster.
Some of the best decisions that
we made, on the other hand,
as Norman said,
we had good tools,
which meant that even when
we threw out prototypes,
although we wasted things
like art resources and things
like that, we actually didn't
end up wasting very much code,
because things like the
idea of workers or cities
could literally be pulled
out of the old games we had,
put into our new game,
and then reworked
to build our new structure.
We also weren't afraid
to trust each other
and throw out the
things that didn't work.
Once we started
moving fast, we had
a lot of ideas that
would come out,
and we would say, OK,
this doesn't work.
We're actually
going to scrap it.
Or we think that this isn't
the direction we need to go in.
And everybody was willing
to go along with it.
It's not a good feeling to
see your things thrown out.
But everybody understood that
was for the best of the game.
And I really appreciate their
understanding with everything
too.
And part of that all
comes down to the fact
that we were on board
with our final idea.
We were all excited about
the concept that we had.
Part of that might
have been the relief
of coming to a concrete
idea after spending
so much time being vague.
But once we had
the concrete idea,
we really moved fast and
worked well around it.
So thank you and any questions.
AUDIENCE: Who did your sound?
It's awesome.
MATT: That was from our UI team.
AUDIENCE: Oh, [INAUDIBLE].
OK, I really liked it.
MATT: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Where did you find it?
NORMAN: So it's on
our credits page.
Most of it was online.
The credits page in our game.
AUDIENCE: And so you
don't want to type it in.
MATT: It's a little
small, I guess, up here.
AUDIENCE: Oh, OK, great.
MATT: But it looks--
AUDIENCE: [? Switch games. ?]
NORMAN: Yeah, "Hold
My Hand," AGP by--
AUDIENCE: Would it be possible
to do a [? shortened ?]
URL of these?
MATT: For the game?
Oh, yeah, sure.
We can make a Bitly link, and
we'll send it out to everyone.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, just
to entire-- yeah.
MATT: That's a good call.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Having
watched the early crash
and burn playthrough,
how often do people--
I don't know if
you've actually had
a lot of people to play your
current version of your game.
Do people usually take
a playthrough or two
before they start
getting the concept?
MATT: Yes.
That's why something like a
tutorial would be really nice.
Unfortunately, we didn't
have the time to put it in.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, no.
I was wondering how that-- OK.
MATT: Yeah, usually
what happens is,
even if after maybe a couple of
turns of playing through they
start to get the idea,
the problem is that,
as the water starts to rise,
they haven't prepared enough.
And so all their workers or
the toys will starve or get
carried away by the waves,
which is a bit unfortunate
and probably makes the players
feel bad on the first time.
But then they-- it
actually teaches
them to think ahead about it.
So the next playthrough,
they're much more careful
and understanding.
AUDIENCE: Yes, I
was wondering if you
were playing any other games
or thinking about other games
as the inspiration
or thinking about how
to deal with sort of
getting the right level
of strategic thinking
in your game.
NORMAN: Well, so I guess
in terms of early on.
Because we had a
very different idea
of what we wanted to do
early on in the process,
we were thinking about games
like Civilization and how
did they communicate all
these complex worker movements
and managing multiple cities.
But once we actually came
up with this game concept,
I think we had much,
much smaller goals.
And so did we have any specific
game models, do you think?
MATT: There is none that
I specifically think of.
There were some things that
we were sort of inspired by,
standard tricks,
like when you hover
over one of the
characters, they got
bigger, some idea of showing
off that this is clickable,
things like that.
But specific games
themselves, not really.
AUDIENCE: I was just
thinking it ended up
being kind of war gamey.
And I feel like there's
a lot of war games
that where I'd thinking
a lot about getting
that right level of I guess
tactics rather than strategy.
But, yeah, I guess it
worked out kind of.
AUDIENCE: So you
mentioned that you
were able to completely
change how your workers looked
and just keep your models.
So that's sort of the Holy Grail
of object-oriented programming,
that kind of object
that's reusable
and you don't have to
throw out the code.
Do you think there's a reason
why, in particular, you
were able to achieve that,
because I think that's not--
that's not common necessarily
in object-oriented programming?
NORMAN: Partially, a
little bit of OCD-ness
like very early on,
very strictly saying
we're going to write this
object-oriented code,
and we're not just going
to hack things together.
I think that helped a
lot, because we actually
spent the time in
the very beginning
to think about
like which objects
were responsible for what and
what their purpose should be.
Yeah, basically,
I think because we
moved more slowly in
the start and thought
more carefully about how that
code should be structured,
we ended up with having
an easier time later on.
MATT: There's also the
fact that because we
had learned these things
from the prototype
that we are putting into
this game, that also meant
that the objects that we
created because we wanted
similar functionality to
things that we had already seen
and we knew worked,
it meant that we
were comfortable pulling out
the functionality into that.
I don't want to say it
was designed to fit.
But there is the fact that we
moved it on purpose, really.
AUDIENCE: I would like
to say something on it.
So we had a very good MVC model.
So models were at and has
a tree-like structure,
I think it was very easy to
change the model somewhere else
[? and knew it ?]
involved-- sorry,
used our new evolved models
once [? models and no idea ?]
of what happens.
So basically, it was
[INAUDIBLE] change.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
All right, thank you.
MIRIAM: Hello, my
name is Miriam.
And today, I'm going to be
presenting for Team Heat Wave.
And we made a game
called Heat Wave.
So the goal of Heat
Wave was and is
to educate Red Cross
workers about how to prepare
for and handle heat waves.
And if you've never been
through a heat wave,
it's just defined as
elevated temperatures
for an extended period of time.
And the way you
prepare for that is you
set up umbrellas for shade.
You get water coolers.
And during the
actual event, you try
to go inside and drink an
excess amount of water.
So while we had that
game goal, we also
had design goals of usability,
playability, and education--
usability because if
the game doesn't open,
it doesn't turn on,
that's a problem,
it doesn't work, playability
because we wanted people
to be able to play
through the whole game,
it's just very fundamental,
and education because this game
is meant to educate Red
Cross workers about how
to deal with heat waves.
So we really wanted that to be
one of our primary objectives
for the game.
So to meet these goals, we
had our design processes.
And I'll talk a
little bit about each
of these in detail in a minute.
But we started off
just as the other teams
did with brainstorming.
Then we formed a team
based off of our ideas.
And then we broke
down responsibility.
So one person was in charge
of one aspect of the game.
Another was in charge
of like the graphics,
all separate tasks.
And then we
continuously updated.
And what we used for that
was Trello, primarily.
And I'll talk more
about that in a minute.
So brainstorming,
we were actually
right there on the board
drawing things for a while.
And we had two major ideas
going as a group of people
just considering this topic.
The two ideas we had were the
game we actually came up with,
where you play as a Red Cross
worker trying to help people.
And then our second game
was playing as a heat wave,
trying to make people faint.
And while that actually
sounds like a lot of fun,
we stuck with the first idea.
And the reason we did
that is we thought
we could get more
education into the game.
Because education was such
a primary focus for us,
we really wanted it to be
the core basis of the game.
So we went with the
game that would directly
correlate to what these
Red Cross workers would
be doing out in the streets
before and during a heat wave.
And based off of that
idea, we formed a team.
We actually had a
pretty large team.
This is eight out of
nine of our people.
Joe wasn't in this photo,
because he wasn't there
that day.
But we had a really large team.
So we had to be really focused
as to like who was doing what
and what was getting done when.
Because when you have
such a large team,
things can slip
through the cracks.
So we used Scrum.
And as you can see up there,
it says so many emails,
because there were
so many emails.
But the way we dealt with that
based off of previous projects
was to say, well, we're going
to have a lot of emails.
There's nothing we
can do about that.
But we can make the
emails relevant,
so we can break them
into different threads.
So the people who were
handling the character objects,
they're just going to
have their own thread.
And maybe like one person who's
communicating between teams
will also be on that thread.
But it's really their thread.
So we had a lot of emails.
But they were divided up
as to who got to see them
and who it affected.
And the other thing we
did is we had our Trello.
And we constantly updated that.
And we kept track
of what was being
done in this sprint
and previous sprints.
And it was really
easy to see what
was taking longer
than we expected
and what was done, what was
done but could use improvements.
Like you could make a note.
We had like a
not-done-yet section.
So we really managed to
stay organized that way.
And the other thing we
did to make sure things
got done was group meetings.
And these were quintessential
for our groups.
We had a bunch of like
three-hour long meetings.
And we would get
task after task done,
bug after bug fixed,
and really just worked
through for hours on end.
So once we had this game and
we were all working on it,
we had four focus
tests that we ran.
And they all had a theme.
So our first focus test
was about the concept,
can we educate people in
the basic mechanic of that
we think we're going to use.
And I'll talk about
that in a minute.
The second one was
overarching issues.
So I said our three design goals
were usability, playability,
and education.
So that was really our
second focus assessed.
The third focus
test was visuals.
Are we connecting with the user?
Are these the visuals
we want to have?
And then for the fourth
one was game balancing.
Does this game feel fun to play?
Is it working out?
So the first focus
test, we focused
on the general mechanics.
We had a low fidelity
prototype, which is actually
a Python-based game.
And there was a list of people.
And you could say, I want
to talk to this person based
on some attributes and
offer them water, tell them
to go inside.
And each turn, you could either
continue talking to them,
say forget it, you're
being annoying,
or oh, you accepted
water, I'm going
to move on to the next person.
Or you could do nothing.
And what we learned very
quickly was that it was working.
People were choosing
to try and help
people based on
their characteristics
and based on oh, well, this
person fainted really quickly,
and they were homeless,
so I think homeless people
might faint faster.
Though actually, I don't
think homeless people
were in this game.
And we also experimented with
different types of dialogues.
So we experimented with having
like very factual dialogue,
drinking water is
really important,
even if you're not too
thirsty versus something like,
hide your wife, hide
your kids heat wave.
So once we had that
general concept in place,
we built a basic unit game.
And we wanted to see
overarching issues.
So we had these
four-- well five,
but one person has already
fainted in this picture-- five
different characters with
different attributes.
And you could choose
to talk to them.
It was the same
exact concept we had
in the Python text-based game.
This time, it was a
little more visual.
There were people and there was
a dialogue that would show up.
But it wasn't fully there yet.
And what we saw was the
usability and the playability
were definitely
having issues here.
You can see that.
But the education was
definitely coming through it.
In fact, people wanted
it to be more visual.
And we saw that,
and we said, well,
we have to test more visuals.
So you can see, this was
the version we tested later.
And we said, how is
this working, who
are you choosing to click on?
And people said, well, first
of all, it's confusing.
All these people look the same.
I can kind of tell who's a
woman and who might be a man,
but that's about it.
The labels aren't
moving with the people.
Even if they were
moving with the people,
they're really too small.
We can't tell who's who.
And we said, well,
we have this art
that we think
we're going to redo
all the art in the style of.
We're thinking about
getting rid of the labels.
Do you think that's a good idea?
And they said, yes,
get rid of the labels.
They're too small anyway.
And so we showed them
this caricature of one
of the types of the characters,
which is a homeless person.
They're a very vulnerable
group to heat waves.
We said, this is kind of the
art style we were looking at.
We think it displays
more information.
Do you think that's good?
And we got enormously
positive feedback on that.
They say, definitely, I
would click on this guy,
because he looks
like he needs help.
And you'll see that later.
Something else we were
having an issue with visually
was that the way
people would go inside
is they would just
kind of wander out.
But the way they fainted, they
would actually just disappear,
proof.
So people didn't
notice it actually.
And then they'd
suddenly be like, well,
there was 10 people,
and now there's
five people, and what happened?
So we said, OK, we
know this is an issue.
What do you think would be
the best way to visually show
that people are fainting
and that would emotionally
resonate with you?
And they said, well, we
want them to fall over.
And maybe it'd be nice if
there were some other feedback,
like sound or something.
And we said, OK, we'll
take that a step farther.
And we did.
And we'll talk about that later.
And the third thing
that we really
got back from this visual
feedback focus test
was that there was no indication
when people were getting sick.
So in the real world,
if you're getting sick,
you might like turned
red, get really sweaty.
If you're about to faint, it'll
be very obvious is the point.
And there was no
indication here.
So we said, well, we're going
to do something about it.
We're going to put that
on the back burner,
keep thinking about it.
And we are going to
fix that somehow.
And so we put that
all into practice.
And you'll see the
screens in a bit.
But our final focus test, we
focused on game balancing.
Is this game balanced?
Are people fainting
at a reasonable rate?
The problem was
that we would have
like six people all
fainting at the same time.
They said no, they have to
faint at different increments.
And also on top of
that, we had an issue
where the temperature
was somewhat random,
going up and down.
And people were not
adjusting to that.
One day it was 110.
The next day was 80.
And that's in Fahrenheit,
because I assume most of you
use Fahrenheit typically.
But our game is
actually in Celsius now.
But the idea was
that people were not
adjusting to this change.
And it wasn't realistic.
So what we do now is we actually
ramp up the temperature,
and so that the first day,
very few if any people faint.
And then the next day,
by the end of day,
people start fainting,
because it's getting hot.
And then the third day,
they're fainting faster.
And you'll see that in the
playthrough after this.
So during this whole process, we
made some good and bad choices.
And I'd like to talk
about bad choices first.
So we made two major--
these were the two,
I think, biggest
bad choices we made.
They're not completely
horrible or anything.
The first was that we
depended on external code.
And the second is we focused
on education, not fun.
So when I mentioned the external
code, one of our teammates
had a dialogue system
for unity, which
is really cool, it looked really
nice, had lot of features.
And we said, let's go for it.
We can use this as a foundation
to build a really complex game.
And something we really
didn't stop to think about
was how much work is it
going to be to develop
our game around this system?
How much work is it going
to be to change the system
to fit our game?
And also are we going to
have time to do all of that
and also focus on making the
game complete as a whole,
instead of just kind of
showcasing this one aspect.
And it turns out it was a
bit of a pitfall for us,
because we didn't expect it to
take as much time as it did.
And if we were to go back,
the teams kind of said,
well, maybe we still do this
and we just deal with the issues
early on.
But also, maybe we should have
just designed a simpler game
and not use this external code.
Another bad choice
we made was we
really did focus
on education, which
was good, because our
game does teach people.
But it is an educational
game in the sense
that it's not the
most fun in the world.
And if we were to
redo this, we probably
should have focused
on fun earlier.
We played with
having funny dialogue
and making more emotionally
resonating effects.
But at the end of the day,
it's an educational game.
And it's really not
that exciting to play.
So that's something.
But in the process
of doing that,
we made some good choices too.
And one of those good choices
we made was group meetings.
You get so much done
when you sit down
with like most of your
team for three hours
and you just hammer through.
And we did that multiple times.
And it really worked out for us.
Something else we did
well was prioritize.
Because we had a
team of nine people,
we really had-- availability
was kind of all over the place.
And even when we
had group meetings,
you could only really expect
like six people to show up.
You were guaranteed that at
least three people weren't
going to be there.
Even if you did a
doodle, which we did.
So what we prioritized
was based on group--
we had groups of people with
different responsibilities.
But if there was a bug, we said,
OK, who is available right now?
What are you're working on?
Is this more of a priority?
Can you do this now?
And that process worked for us.
We got bug after bug
fixed that way when
we weren't in a group meeting.
And when we got to
the group meeting,
people generally had a
sense of what was going on,
because we were doing
this process of they
kind of had maybe worked on
something for a little bit
based on it being a priority.
So now, let's get
to the actual game.
So the game has a start screen
within an instruction screen,
which is kind of the sublayer.
The main game, which has
the day scene and then
a newspaper scene at the night,
and I'll show you all these.
And then the end screen.
So originally, this was what
our start screen looked at
that we play tested.
And it was beautiful,
as you can see up there.
No need for changes, right?
So we actually did change it.
And so now, it's
the same background
as a game for Cohesion.
You have your play,
but you can also
use the instructions, which are
pretty useful if you've never
played before.
And then that takes
you to our main game.
Our main game
originally, you saw that
on the first focus test.
I think this is pretty similar
to our second focus test.
You see we had a progression
with the main game.
It took a lot of iteration.
And something originally
we didn't have,
I said, was there
was no indication
of when somebody was getting
sick or their characteristics.
It was a lot of issues.
So we made some progress.
We added the indicator that
say, I'm about to faint.
You should probably
try to help me now,
which is that little explanation
part on part of their head.
And then finally,
we redid pretty much
all of the graphics.
And that took a while.
So we were in the process of
redoing them at this point.
And now, the game
looks like this.
So it's much more cohesive.
All the art fits together.
The people are really
visually caricatures
of the different types of
people you need to help.
Elderly people, homeless
people, drunk people
are all really
vulnerable to heat waves.
And then there's some
characters that actually aren't
on this screen
right here but that
aren't as vulnerable, like
normal, like adults aren't
as vulnerable.
And athletes aren't
So at the end of each day,
when you play this through,
and you've helped your
people, and you've given them
water or set up
coolers or whatever
you wanted to do for the day,
you get to a newspaper scene.
And the original
newspaper scene looked
like this, a lot of text.
It doesn't really
help you with much.
No one really
cared much about it
in the first
iterations of the game,
because the long-term objects
hadn't been adding yet.
So it's just the umbrellas
and the water coolers.
And so we changed it
to look like this.
It's the same information,
just a little better organized.
And the other thing that
we added in the main game,
we added those
buttons that says,
you can set up a water
cooler or an umbrella.
And that takes your time up.
So if it's cool outside,
maybe you do that.
But if it's like 110
degrees in Fahrenheit, then
maybe you should focus on
helping people not faint.
So we had that.
And then say you
finish, 20 people faint
or whatever-- I think
it's 20 people faint--
and you get to the end screen.
And our original game,
we had no end screen.
And the reason for that
was, I told you we really
focused on education not fun.
And we just didn't think,
part of the fun of a game
is seeing how long you survive.
But we just weren't
thinking about that.
So we really reevaluated that.
And we said, OK, we
definitely need an end screen.
And we have it
looking like this.
So it tells you how
long you lasted.
And then you can see
the credits for what
was involved in the game.
And you can play it again.
So there's more feedback for
the user of how they did.
And if we were going to
do this project again,
there's two things I think
we'd do majorly differently.
And the first is talking
about heat waves.
Our group thought heat waves
were going to be really cool.
We were like, oh, people
are fainting everywhere,
and it's getting hot, and
we have to do something.
And then you start
reading about heat waves.
And basically, it gets hot.
You tell people to go
inside or drink water.
And that's about it.
That's all a heat wave is.
And so what we'd do differently
is really the passion aspect.
If we're going to do a
game about heat waves,
we depended kind of
on our passion coming
from the thinking
heat waves were cool.
I think we should
have focused more
on having passion for the
game and then incorporating
the-- well, also having the
game build around heat waves
but really having a more
exciting game that we
could somehow also get
that educational aspect in.
What wed also do differently
is accountability.
I said we had nine people.
Sometimes, people disappear
when you have that many people.
And keeping dibs on
everything, especially when you
have separate email threads,
can be a little confusing.
So maybe look into
some of the tools
that the other teams mentioned,
where you have multiple group
chats and you can see them all.
That looks really interesting.
Future features, more
long-term options.
I think that's one of
the things in our game
that really helps with
the planning aspect is OK,
do I want to be doing this,
like helping somebody now?
Or do I wanting to be
installing an object now?
And really, our
game kind of depends
on that balance of choosing
who to help and then
also what to do.
Am I helping or not?
So more long term options.
And then something we
originally conceived
was to have multiple
environments.
And we didn't have
time to implement this.
But in different
environments, you
do slightly different things.
Like if you're in
an office, you might
want to install an AC unit,
which is different than what
you'd do outside.
So really look into
multiple environments.
Different countries have
different environments,
might have slightly different
strategies for what to do.
And we really would
like to look into that.
So before we play the game, do
you guys have any questions?
In that case, I'd
like a user tester.
AUDIENCE: So someone who
hasn't played the game before,
again one of our guests.
Alex?
AUDIENCE: Sure.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
MIRIAM: It's not
showing up there.
Give me a second.
Display.
You're going to have
to give me a minute.
I didn't realize it
wouldn't show up.
AUDIENCE: Make sure
that's not plugged in.
MIRIAM: Yes.
I [INAUDIBLE] have
it plugged in.
How do I mirror the screens?
Sorry, it just--
otherwise, he's going
to have to stare up there.
Oh, thank you.
Don't look at my emails.
There's so many of them.
OK, yeah.
AUDIENCE: Are we good?
MIRIAM: Yeah, go for it.
My sound is on silent.
There.
AUDIENCE: All right?
Let's see, solo, go
[? to tech ?] the instructions
so thanks for [INAUDIBLE].
All right.
Let me read through
the instructions.
It's going to offer homeless
people water, tell old people
to go inside, install umbrellas,
or many other options.
OK, so pause, click
on Pause button.
OK.
[INAUDIBLE] whoop.
MIRIAM: Sorry,
what just happened?
AUDIENCE: I may have
clicked that actually.
MIRIAM: Oh, did
you start the game?
Here, we'll just quit.
No worries.
Great.
AUDIENCE: OK, thanks.
OK, I think we're ready now.
Let's play.
I'm going for the umbrellas.
OK.
Yeah.
All right.
Wow, that's nice.
Does it get darker
as it goes through?
Cool.
Whoop, uh-oh.
Wake up.
Hey, OK.
Should I do it around here?
MIRIAM: Yeah, sorry.
Go through again.
Try talking to someone.
AUDIENCE: All right.
Is it--
MIRIAM: No, it's something long.
AUDIENCE: Oh, OK.
No worries.
MIRIAM: All right, that's good.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Maybe, just
start the game over.
MIRIAM: Yeah, should
I just-- yeah.
It was working.
OK, let me refresh the page.
There.
AUDIENCE: Oh, there you go.
MIRIAM: I don't
know what happened.
Sorry about that.
AUDIENCE: No worries.
Oh, I see, you can give
them options to do.
Oh, OK, that changes
it just a little, yeah.
MIRIAM: Kind of
important, just a little.
AUDIENCE: All right.
Oh, OK.
Let's see, I'll talk to her.
Uh-oh.
Oh no.
AUDIENCE: I actually caught
the rest of the game.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
Any last questions
for the group?
AUDIENCE: I liked
the bird sounds
and also the fire sounds.
Are there other sound effects?
MIRIAM: So we had music.
But it was really hard to find
good music for a heat wave,
because you think it sounds
hot and you don't really
think of anything.
So we had this very eerie music,
which didn't really fit either.
So we went for the
minimalistic bird
sounds, because we thought
it was the only thing
that kind of fit.
Is there any other sounds?
No.
Yeah, we had other sounds.
Just they sounded wrong.
We had fire sounds, like
in the background and that
made the whole
thing sound really
dangerous and terrifying, which
is not what we want to portray.
We want to portray that you
can do something and prevent
anything bad from happening.
And any other questions?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So a lot of things
have changed in your game
since Monday.
A lot has changed since Monday.
How did you manage the process?
MIRIAM: So we
actually, we were going
to have a meeting before Monday.
But really, our schedules
didn't work out.
So we actually had, I
told you, group meetings.
That's where we got
everything done.
We had like a three, four-hour
group meeting on Monday night,
which we were planning to have.
And while there was like
a couple core things
that we wanted to fix,
just like small like bugs
that we were
working on, and also
while some people were
doing that, we're just like,
well, we have other people
who aren't doing anything
and can't really help with
what's the major thing,
so why don't we just
like add other features,
like it getting light and dark.
Because that's something
we really had considered
and we hadn't had time for.
But in that group meeting,
where somebody had time,
we were able to add that.
And it looks good.
AUDIENCE: How did you test it?
Like, did you--
MIRIAM: Oh, so we've
been running it
like nonstop all of
yesterday and today.
But then it broke.
AUDIENCE: Yep,
definitely, it happens.
MIRIAM: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: You also
went from a screen that
had pretty small
characters on it
to a screen where the
characters were about
3/4 the size of the screen.
How did that
decision come about?
MIRIAM: So we had our drawings.
And when I told you
we focused tested,
then we had like a big
picture of them on the screen.
People loved it.
But when we actually put
them onto the old screen,
they were really
small and you couldn't
see their characteristics.
And we said it's better to have
people overlapping more often
but actually being able to
see their characteristics.
Because the
caricatures are really
where the learning comes in.
Like, if you didn't notice,
the people who fainted
were, I think, the drunk
people and an old person.
So you start to
notice as you play
the game, OK,
homeless people faint
really fast if you
don't give them water.
And that's just like a fact.
People who are
homeless typically
don't have enough
fluids in them.
And they're also outside a lot.
So it's really hot.
So that's relearning comes in.
So we wanted to
make those bigger.
And to make them bigger,
we thought, OK, we'll
just put in like a simpler
one-lane background.
So that's where that came from.
We were planning on doing
that before yesterday, I
mean before Monday.
But we just didn't
have the assets in yet.
So like a lot of things changed
that were already in the works
since you last saw it.
Cool.
Any other questions?
Well, thank you so much.
LAUREN: All right, so
we're Cholera Control.
And we're going to talk a
little bit about our game
and the making of it.
So firstly, Cholera Control is a
game we made for the Red Cross.
Our client was Pablo Sanchez,
as a few others have mentioned.
And the point that we wanted
to get across with our cholera
game is that it is an easily
preventable disease, if you
just like wash your hands.
It's really not that hard.
But people just
don't seem to do it,
because there's a lot of
factors going on in their life
and they sort of just forget.
But it's really easy to do,
if you just wash your hands.
So we want to just do a
quick demo of the game.
Where is-- OK.
So if someone would like to
come down and play our game.
AUDIENCE: OK.
LAUREN: Cool.
AUDIENCE: Cholera is fun.
AUDIENCE: Not supposed to
show up on our home video,
so that's OK.
AUDIENCE: Are you hot?
AUDIENCE: No, I'm just kidding.
I don't know.
AUDIENCE: We'll find out.
Don't have any policy for that.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Play a game.
LAUREN: Can you guys read that?
AUDIENCE: Yep.
LAUREN: Can anyone in
the back not read it?
Because, it--
STUDENT: It says
cholera is spreading.
You got to control it and
watch out for outbreaks.
AUDIENCE: OK, I'll
just-- Oh, OK.
I have $1,400?
LAUREN: So as you
can see, the game
is kind of a strategy game.
Right now, there's only
one locality to deal with.
We sort of didn't want to
throw too much at the player
at the very beginning.
So you can kind of--
also, the game is paused,
so it's going to open
in that corner there.
And so you can have time
to sort of just read,
make sure you know
what's going on,
what all those
different things do.
Then you go back to the map.
And time keeps elapsing.
And so over time, more
localities appear, up to four.
So right now, you just
get the second one.
They are on different
branches of the river.
So they're not going to really
hurt each other right now,
still relatively easy.
STUDENT: We go cheap.
LAUREN: Hopefully.
I don't want to offend
anyone, if they're like,
this is really hard.
AUDIENCE: So the
average [INAUDIBLE]
that the infection is
still growing, more so.
LAUREN: So one of the
things you could see,
if he goes back to the
map, is all the bars
above the villages, green is
the healthy and red is infected.
And there's an
arrow, which I think
is a-- you can see it pretty
well on there-- the arrow,
if it's pointing that way, that
means that the amount of green
is growing.
So there's more
people getting healed.
If it's pointing the other
way, then more people
are getting infected,
which is bad.
So if you see your
arrow switch directions,
you usually want to
get on that really
quickly and make sure that
nobody dies-- well, no, nobody
gets infected.
Nobody dies in this game.
We didn't want to be too harsh.
AUDIENCE: Are the
products accumulated?
So my like--
STUDENT: Yes, yeah, so
if you buy more than one,
they work together.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Ew, boiling water.
STUDENT: So boiling
water is special,
because it helps
downstream villages.
AUDIENCE: I clicked that.
STUDENT: That doesn't help.
AUDIENCE: I know.
Is my budget growing?
STUDENT: Yes.
AUDIENCE: OK, oh great.
Oh, crap, I didn't
mean to do that.
STUDENT: You can undo.
AUDIENCE: Oh, I can?
STUDENT: Yeah,
well, now you can't.
AUDIENCE: Now, I can't.
STUDENT: That one's going
to-- you're [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: OK, I need to buy them
boiling water, and that's it.
STUDENT: You're done.
AUDIENCE: OK.
LAUREN: Well, thank you.
STUDENT: Yep, thanks.
Yeah, so if you manage to
survive longer-- no offense--
you get to-- up to
four villages pop up,
or four localities pops up.
And then it gets really hard.
Cool.
Cool, so first, we're going
to talk about what went right,
both from the
creation of the game
and working as a team
sort of perspective.
LAUREN: So firstly, I'll
go over the iteration
was a lot better
on this project.
In this class, we had a
total of four projects.
The first three were
each over-- like,
the first one was two weeks.
Second one was two weeks.
Third one was two weeks.
And then this one
was eight weeks.
So this time, we had a
lot more time to sort
of decide what we wanted to
do, what we should try out,
and get to sort of test each and
every single one of the ideas
that we had, rather
than just focusing
on one idea of having to do it,
because you only had two weeks.
The other thing is that
after three projects,
we finally figured out how to
do design meetings really well.
We got them down to that they
were only like a half hour
each.
And when people showed up,
they were really productive.
And so everyone figured
out what they wanted to do.
They talked about the game.
It got done, and people
got out of there.
It was very nice.
Another thing we did
right was simplifying.
It was really hard
to adjust scope.
It was easier in
the other games,
because you realize you
only have two weeks.
When you have eight weeks,
you think you can do a lot,
and you really can't.
You think you have
a lot of time,
but classes and
applying to jobs,
and everything takes
all of your time.
And so you have to
really learn to,
OK, like, I only have so
much time for this class.
I can only do so
much on this game,
so I'm going to
adjust the scope.
And it was really hard even when
the client, when Pablo told us,
you should change what you're
doing, we didn't want to.
We thought, no, this
is a great idea.
This is how it should work.
But then when the
client tells you do it
and all your play testers
say your idea is bad,
you need to just
give in and change.
And we ended up having
really great results.
With the simpler gameplay,
it's a lot more fun.
And the options, there
are less options,
but they're much
more meaningful.
As you could see,
the player was sort
of reading through
each and every option.
And it's because they each
do something different.
Before, we had a
lot more options.
But they were all
sort of the same.
You just kind of click
them, and they do something.
But they're all just
about the same effect.
With this, they all
have different effects.
So you sort of
have to strategize.
Do I want to spend more
money for this effect?
Or can I just use this cheaper
effect over and over again
for the same result?
STUDENT: So I'm going to
talk a little bit about what
changed from beginning to end.
So the UI in the beginning
looks much uglier.
I mean, that just came
with sort of refining that.
I want to talk a lot about
sort of the design changes
that really changed.
So in our first
prototype of the game,
you sort of click these
buttons here on the right.
And that would give
you the actions.
Whereas, in the final
version of the game,
you click on the villages, and
that gives you the actions.
And this came from
something that Pablo
told us early on and really
made a big difference, which
is like people that are used
to playing video games get
this concept of click
action, apply to object.
But we realized, both through
play testing and again
Pablo telling us,
that when you don't
have that sort of experience,
working in a lot of videogames
and just having that
context in your head,
that doesn't really make sense.
It makes much more
sense to the people
that we're aiming this game
for to click on the object
and then choose an action.
So like that inverting
of the order of things
actually makes a big
difference in helping
to understand the
game and just making
the whole thing smoother.
On top of that, we
sort of like really
refined the information
that we're showing
when you look at the map.
So right now, like in
the original version,
you look at the
map and you sort of
don't see straight away
everything you need to see.
You need to go to
each of the villages
individually to know
what's going on.
You sort of can only see
where each village is,
or where each locality is
and how much health it has.
Whereas in the final version,
we sort of give you every you
need to see.
And it took a long
time to figure out
how we wanted to do this UI.
Like, how do we show
what prevention measures
are in place?
How do we show
whether the infection
is growing or decreasing?
And how do we show which
way the river is flowing?
All of these questions were
really important and really led
into the final design.
Secondly, about like
options, at first we
had lots of options, too many.
People did not even want to
figure out what each of them
did.
It was too much
information thrown at once.
And although we thought
that having lots of options
would lead to meaningful--
like, oh, well,
you can make these
advanced strategies.
It really didn't, because
people didn't even want
to bother learning all that.
Whereas, in the final
version, having fewer options
made it much easier or
like much less scary
when you opened up the list
of options, the actions
that you have available
to you as a player.
And it was much more
accessible, while still
making the strategies diverse.
So now, we're going
to talk a little bit
about what went wrong in the
process of making the game.
So working together
is really hard,
because people are
stepping over their toes.
Oh, what do I do now.
Oh, I can't touch that,
because you're touching that.
Like, all these sort
of problem arise.
And so at first, we really
tried to avoid that.
But then we realized working
apart is even harder than that.
Initially, you think,
well, if we're each
working on really sort
of independent parts
and we bring it all together
in the end, that'll be happy.
Everyone will be happy.
We're not stepping on our toes.
We can each work on our own
time and that sort of thing.
But that turns out not to work
well, because people do things
differently.
People follow-- like,
even simple things,
like coding style and how
you name your variables
and all that sort of
stuff makes a difference.
And if you're not
working together closely,
and if you sort of
working apart, bringing
that together was a
huge hassle at the end.
Like we spent a lot of time
just making sure everything,
all the components that
we had made as individuals
worked together, just
to get the game running.
LAUREN: So another
thing that went wrong
was the motivation
for this project.
At the very beginning,
the team wasn't
very passionate about the
project to begin with,
which is really hard.
It's really hard to
work on something
that you don't really
love and want to do.
And I thought, you know, maybe
this will just get better.
People will start to have ideas.
They'll feel ownership
of the project.
And then they'll be more
motivated to work on it.
But that's not true.
People, if they start
off in a bad place,
they're not going
to get any better.
You really have to focus
on somehow helping people
to either learn to
love the project
or learn to just be
able to work on it.
And this can be done
through different ways.
The easiest way is
just to get people
to realize like we
have to do this,
so you have to work on it.
And I found it as-- towards
the end of the semester,
it took me to
figure this one out.
But if you give people
vague instructions,
they will wait until
the very last second.
But if you make
it crystal clear,
exactly what you want
them to do and give
them is as detailed
instructions you can,
it's much more likely that it'll
get done in a timely manner.
And also, we felt
really restricted
by the topic and
the requirements,
which was another just
problem in motivation.
And so crunch is something
I was sort of alluding to,
is that when you
have the instructions
and you don't want to do
something, you will put it off.
I do it.
I am sure everyone else does it
that I don't want to do this.
I don't understand what
they want me to do,
so I'm just going to wait
until the last possible second
when I have to do it
or I'm going to fail.
And that's when it
gets done, which
is what I think was a
leading thing to our crunch.
And so we had
constant crunching.
Every time we knew
we had to play test,
the night before,
everyone was up working.
And there was a huge
crunch after Thanksgiving.
We took until Thanksgiving,
and then everyone
realized we don't have that much
for longer in this semester.
We only have like a
week and three days
before this final presentation.
So there was a lot
of crunch there.
And the work was low priority
because of other classes,
which is a really unique problem
to doing a school project, as
opposed to doing a
project in the real world,
where people still might
have other things to do,
but this is their job.
Whereas, when this is a
class, you can't really
fire someone from your class.
Let's see, you want to
talk about what we learned?
STUDENT: Yeah.
So what we learned in terms of
game design, at least for me
and probably for everyone on the
team, what was most surprising
is that giving more choices and
making a game more complicated
does not make it more fun.
Initially I thought,
more choices
means more strategic
diversity or whatever,
and that'll make
everything more exciting.
And every time
you play the game,
you can try something different.
But that's not really true.
Having less choices
can be even more
fun than having more
choices, because then you
don't have-- like when
the player doesn't have
to think about as
much at once, they
can really go deeper into
what the current options are.
So that was really surprising.
Also in terms of game design,
requirements can be restrictive
and often you can't do
what you want to do.
You as a designer can't
do what you want to do,
can't fulfill your own fantasy
for what the game is opposed
to look like, because
of the requirements,
because of what clients want,
and because of what players
want.
And you have to learn to
sort of deal with that.
The designer is
not always right.
Just because I have an idea
for what the game is supposed
to look like, if I
test on 10 people
and all 10 people
say I don't like it,
I'd prefer it to be this
way, then I'm wrong.
I have to change that.
And that's something
that's hard to deal with,
but it's something you
have to learn to do.
Yeah, we learned a
lot about cholera.
Basically, as we said
in one of first slides,
washing hands is
overpowered in real life.
If you just wash-- very simple
things can prevent cholera.
And that's something we wanted
to get across in this game.
In the game, washing hands
is overpowered, just so
that they get that idea across.
And about coding, there's
a lot of simple things
you can do to really
polish up the game,
like tweening, which is a
animation API available,
and Phaser that we used.
But really any animation API
that does like little things,
like having the window
pop up instead of just
appear, having things go like
"paching!" and move in and out,
that makes a huge difference
for very little effort.
And it makes the game
look much more polished.
In terms of future changes
for the game itself,
we initially planned to
have seasons and lots
of random events that would sort
of make the game more exciting,
especially near the end,
once all four villages are up
and you sort of get
into this pattern.
But we basically didn't
have time to do that.
And then the second thing that
at least I personally wanted
to add to the game was more
advanced infection models.
It turns out that modeling
infection is-- well,
it's not surprising really.
But modeling infection
is really hard.
Balancing your
model of infection
is really, really hard.
And it's sort of
almost impossible
to make it have this
sort of smooth curve,
where it starts out
easy and then gets
sort of hard at the
end but not too hard.
Infection is
exponential in nature.
And that's really
hard to deal with.
If I had more time
to work on it,
I'd probably spend
a lot more time
thinking about different
models to use for infection
and make it easier to balance.
Like right now, you change
like one little number
by hardly anything,
and the game goes
from really, really easy
to completely impossible,
just because of the
nature of infection.
LAUREN: And lastly, future
changes for the class.
One of things that we all
felt would be really useful
is if the professors had
enforced the sprint task
list, because you could
submit your sprint task list
at the beginning of your week.
But you never had to tell them
if you actually did everything.
You just had another
sprint task list,
which maybe if that it
was looked at carefully,
there might be the exact same
things two weeks in a row.
But a lot of times, you
never heard anything
about your progress.
You just kind of
had your progress.
And it wasn't until
the end that we really
realized like, oh, we're
kind of far behind.
We need to fix that.
So it would have been nice
earlier in the project
to have that sort of feedback,
like, hey, you should be--
are these things done?
You should be doing more.
And more freedom in
choosing the topic,
like we mentioned before,
we felt really restricted.
There were things we wanted to
do that we couldn't, because
of the confines of this project.
And so a little more
freedom would've been nice.
But you know, it's a class.
So finally, does anyone have
any questions or comments,
feedback?
AUDIENCE: OK.
What would you do
if-- what would
your team have done if they
were able to choose a topic
or have a little
bit more freedom?
Was there anything in particular
you talked about as a team?
Or when you're talking about
things you wanted to do
but the client said no.
AUDIENCE: Humor.
STUDENT: Yeah, in terms of like
if we were doing about cholera,
things we wanted
to do about cholera
but we couldn't, like
death is not in the game.
We can't make it like
overly morbid or anything,
not that we-- But there
are certain things,
like we wanted to
have more options.
But since the game is sort of
oriented towards-- or rather,
the options have to be
oriented towards what
an individual can do.
So the game is
supposed to teach kid
to young adult as an
individual how can I
prevent cholera, which is
like you wash your hands.
You boil your water,
that sort of thing.
But things like put basically
bathrooms, the sorts of things
that a government or the group
of people as a whole could do,
but an individual
can't really do,
were options that we
wanted in the game,
and could have sort of
interesting mechanical effects
within the game, we couldn't do,
because it doesn't make sense.
I can't teach you
to make bathrooms.
You can't, not really,
as an individual.
LAUREN: Yeah, and sort
of as Jen shouted out,
tongue-in-cheek humor.
There was a lot of
time during the game
where we're like, oh, we
should have this happen,
but it was offensive.
It was funny.
It would be funny to
an American audience.
But because it was for
an audience in Ghana,
we changed the-- we
didn't know whether to use
village or town or city.
And so we asked Pablo.
And he said use the
word locality, which
to everyone playing
it, play testers,
we're like this is
a really weird word.
Why does it say locality?
And even we forget to
use the word locality.
And we call it a
village accidentally.
And so we'd want a little
bit more freedom there
and sort of make it maybe
a more humorous game.
But we didn't really--
we were really
afraid of being offensive.
That was like one
of the first things
we talked about when
we started making
the game is how do we make
sure we don't offend anybody
accidentally.
AUDIENCE: Any other questions?
We're done?
All right.
LAUREN: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
LIZ RITA: We're the
Saving Gora Gora team.
I'm Liz, Rachel, Kevin, Justin.
There are others
in the audience.
Go to the beginning.
Yeah.
So to start us off, I'm going
to talk about, let's see,
the goals that we had
from the beginning.
Our product is about cholera
and cholera prevention.
And our audience was
Ghanaian children.
So we had to find a way to
connect Ghanaian children
to this information
about cholera
prevention, positive behaviors,
proactive things they can
do in the community, while
also having a fun game
that they can relate to.
What this ultimately
meant is that we
had to do a lot of
research, because we
didn't have a direct
connection with our audience.
And we couldn't
directly play test
with children from
Ghana, ages 8 to 13.
We had to make a lot of
assumptions, which ended up
being wrong after we talked to
Pablo, specifically about them.
So we did some more research.
We looked at Ghana,
cartoons targeted
towards children in Ghana.
And from those cartoons, we
looked at the color palettes,
some behaviors within
the cartoon specifically,
and names and sort of character
designs from the cartoons.
And we got Ghana research
from documentaries and stuff,
also informed decisions that
we used to change minigames,
which we'll talk about
later in the presentation.
A quick overview of the
narrative-- you start the game.
There is this monster
hiding in a bush.
You go to check him out.
It turns out that
he's being persecuted,
because everybody in
Gora Gora is sick.
And they think he's the cause.
And Sal is actually a cool guy.
You're a bunny, and
your name is Kojo,
and you're a cool guy, too.
So you're asked to prove
that he's innocent.
And you take that up, because
you're an awesome person.
The gameplay ends
up being that you
explore the town,
looking for ways
to prove that Sal is innocent.
And you do that by
unlocking these minigames
and getting clues
from the minigames
after you defeat the minigames.
And after each minigame, you
can go talk to the mayor,
or you have the choice to,
because he has an office.
And when you have all
the clues, you finally
convince the mayor that Sal
is harmless, which is great.
KEVIN WANG: So
our first minigame
dealt with water filtration.
And the concept behind it is
that friends and neighbors
are bringing containers
of water to Kojo's mom.
And they want to see whether
the water is safe to drink,
or whether they have to purify
it beforehand by boiling.
So that, and when we
initially designed our game,
it turned out to be water
filtration kind of factoring,
in which bottles of water were
going down a conveyor belt.
And you were asked to remove
the bottles that were unpurified
and that needed to be cleaned.
So as you see on the left, that
was our very first iteration.
And I guess the issue with
that, as Pablo brought up to us,
was that it wasn't
relatable to the kids
that we were trying to target,
because these kids likely
won't ever see a facility that
has these conveyor belts, that
does this kind of purification.
So we had to go through
several iterations
to figure out a way to make
the game a lot more relatable.
And our final product is on the
left-- or on the right, sorry.
And as you can see,
it's outside one
of the homes in the village.
And your mom is just standing
behind a pot of boiling water.
And now, you just have plain
containers, bowls, buckets,
tanks.
And your goal is to kind of see
where the water is coming from,
how warm it is, and try
to figure out whether you
want to boil it or not.
So some challenges we faced
were, in our first iteration,
it was more of a
real time game play.
You were kind of rushing
against time to pull off
all the unfiltered water,
as all the bottles continued
to scroll to the
right, regardless
of how fast you were going.
But then we realized
that took away kind
of from the educational aspect,
because it forced the player
to just kind of hurriedly just
pull everything that they can.
So instead, we changed
it to a styled gameplay
that was kind of at
the player's pace.
They can do everything as
fast or as slow as they want.
And that, I think, gives
the player a better chance
to kind of learn
everything there
is to learn from the minigame.
RACHEL WANG: Cool, so the second
minigame is a water collection
game, where you're asked to help
your friend [? Korku ?] find
where to collect water from.
And so with this
development process,
it was kind of
similar to what Kevin
was saying about making it,
like have as high of a learning
value as possible.
And then another aspect of this
game was making it fail-safe.
So obviously, we thought
there was one right answer
that the player should
take away from it.
But we didn't want
them to fail and then
not win the game at the end,
if they were to not choose
the right location.
So one way we dealt
with that was,
every time the player chose
a wrong location, there'd
be immediate feedback,
saying, oh, this
isn't such a good place to
collect water from because.
And so as you can
see, this example
is, if you were to collect
water from the river,
you don't know if there's
excreta from upstream
or if someone's peeing
in the river right now.
So then it'll ask you
to try another place.
We also did a feature
cut pretty early on,
which was also finding someone
to dispose of your excreta.
And so we focused on the
water, which would hopefully
focus the player's
attention in figuring out
where to place water and really
think about the water aspect
and not so much as another
aspect of the game.
So the other challenge
was, as Liz and Kevin
already pointed out, was there's
a huge cultural difference.
So again, I have like a
before and after shot of what
our landscape looked like.
And so originally, there
was snow-capped mountains,
a lot of grass.
But from our research, we
saw that this didn't really
look like Ghana landscape.
We had a water
treatment facility,
which originally was the correct
place to collect water from.
But we eventually changed
that to be a well.
And so that's more
realistic in terms of where
people collect water in Ghana.
Additionally, at the
end there is a task bar,
so it provides
you more feedback.
If you clicked on
any of the buildings
it'll provide you feedback
about what that place is,
and whether or not you
should or shouldn't
be placing water there.
JUSTIN MARTINEZ:
Our final minigame
is focused around teaching
the symptoms of cholera
and the importance
of early prevention
and recognizing the
early signs of cholera
to prevent the disease
from spreading.
So the premise of this game
is that the doctor in the town
is very busy.
He can't go out into
the town to actually
check on patients to see
if they're seeing any
of the early signs of cholera.
So he asks you to help him
by going out and talking
to some of your friends in
town, and then asking them
if they're having
any of the symptoms,
and then ask them to
come in to the doctor.
We initially started
off by having
this game be a game where you
help the doctor in the doctor's
office.
And he's diagnosing
patients, and you're
sort of diagnosing
the patients with him.
And we realized that
this would quickly
turn into sort of a
quiz-type of game,
and it would really detract
from the learning aspect.
It would essentially the same
as just reading the systems out
of a pamphlet.
So we decided that by adding
more interactivity by forcing
the player to go
out into the village
and actually find
people and talk to them
and then ask them to
come to the clinic
would be a lot more engaging,
while still maintaining
the same educational aspect
about trying to search
for the right symptoms.
Additionally, we
made a change where
we had the player go talk to
some of the villagers that
were adults.
And then we realized that--
after speaking with Pablo,
that the social
hierarchy in Ghana
is not necessarily that
of the United States.
And this sort of
interaction, where
a child asks something or
sort of demands something
of an adult, isn't
really something
that would happen, just
because of the stricter
social hierarchy.
So we decided that it'd
be more appropriate if we
had the child go talk
to some of his friends
that were of the same age.
And then tell
them, since they're
on the same sort of level,
to go to the doctor's office,
rather than talking to elders.
Some of the
challenges that we saw
were that this game is
heavily dialogue-based.
It's almost entirely interacting
through our dialogue UI.
And so we needed to do a lot
of iteration on that in order
to make sure that it was
clear who was speaking
and give the appropriate choices
so that the player can make
meaningful decisions while
having his interactions
with the villagers.
And finally, since it
is so dialogue-heavy,
there's a problem that comes
when making a game for children
when you have a lot of
text, because they might not
be the strongest reader.
So we focused w
lot on making sure
that the vocabulary
was simple, and we
tried to keep the sentence
structure as simple
as possible, and
straightforward,
to get the message
across to children.
So some of the
overall challenges
that we faced while doing
the game development
was mastering the
states with Phaser.
This is sort of an intricacy
of the Phaser engine
itself, where when you spawn
off the different stages
of the map, making sure
that we can maintain
the data across all
these different states,
so that there can be a sort
of progress through the game.
And finally, we want to make
sure that the game wasn't
too difficult. For example,
with the facility game
at the beginning when we had
the very fast-paced clicking,
and then you would fail
almost all the time.
We wanted to make sure that
it wasn't too difficult,
and that it was accessible.
The cultural disconnect
we touched a bit
on in some of our
previous games,
making sure that the
target audience will
be able to play this
game and relate to it
in order to pull
the message from it,
and making the play meaningful.
We wanted to make sure that
the game play was still
getting the message across,
and finding a good balance
between education and play.
RACHEL WANG: So
now I'll talk about
how our teamwork
worked out, and what
our process like as a team.
So we used four main tools.
The first one being Trello,
to keep track of our tasks
and progresses.
So, we'd put all our sprint
task lists, our product backlog,
on to the Trello.
People would claim
the different tasks,
and then be able to say
if they were doing them,
if they were done, or
if they haven't started.
And then that means
we could track
how people's progress was.
The second one was
weekly meetings.
So, every week we had
a meeting to either do
some research about Ghana,
talk about how we could improve
the game play and make
it more meaningful,
if we should cut some
features, and whatnot.
So, these meetings were really
great for quick and efficient
decisions, and also really
important decisions.
Our third tool was Slack, which
some other teams talked about.
But it was really great because,
first, they had Google Drive
integration, so you could see
when people were pushing code
if you should be pulling code.
And then, in addition, we
could have different channels.
So we had a separate
coding channel,
where all the coders
could talk to each other,
and that might not be
relevant to other people.
And then having a
whole team channel
was also efficient,
because it would
be faster response than email.
And then our final
one was Google Drive,
which is where we
have all our assets,
had all our dialogues,
our characters.
And this worked out to
be a really great tool
for collaborative storage.
Some downfalls of
this was-- I'll
talk about the second
part, was basically
with all these tools you need
to make sure that everyone's
actually using the tools.
It's not actually effective
to be using Trello
if not everyone's using Trello.
And we found this
to be the case,
not everyone would be updating
their progress on Trello,
or not everyone
would be on Slack .
But some mitigations
we had to that
is, in like Slack, you can
mention people's names,
and then it'll
send them an email
if they're not actually
on Slack at that time.
We did have to remind people
to be updating the Trello board
or updating their progress
in Slack, or just ping
people individually in email.
But I think we worked it out.
Something we could
have improved on
was enforcing deadlines,
and having deadlines.
As Kevin will talk about, we had
different roles between coding
and art designing.
So, obviously the
art assets had to be
done before you could really
code things and put it
into the game.
So in that aspect, we
should have probably
had clearer deadlines
so that we could
stick to a stricter schedule.
And then, in addition,
we should have probably
had a bit more
frequent communication
with the entire team.
So we did have a lot
of communication,
but sometimes not all the
team members were present,
and we should have
probably improved
a bit about sending
out meeting notes
and catching up people who
weren't at the meetings
when we made certain decisions.
And to that regard,
something that we could just
do for next time is,
send out meeting notes,
and keep everyone up
to date, and possibly
even have smaller meetings
where not everyone is present.
So I guess in terms of
what went right, Kevin
will talk about that.
KEVIN WANG: So, as
Rachel was saying,
we separated a lot of the tasks
of the project between the team
members.
And since we had
seven people, we
designated four to coding,
two to design and art,
and then a few others
to the other aspects
such as narrative, project
management, and sound.
So, that actually
helped us a lot,
in that having only four
coders rather than seven really
cut down on the number of
merge conflicts and issues
that we had in
previous projects.
Because, obviously,
the fewer number
of people working on each
file, the less likely
it's all going to
break when people merge
their stuff together in GitHub.
And with the art
designers, it actually
helped to have just two.
Because, although they
had to do more work,
it was easier for them to
collaborate and make sure
that all of their art followed
the same theme, rather than
coming from three or four
different sources that
look slightly different.
Eduardo and Liz were very
capable in making sure
that all the art had the
same kind of color palate,
and the same kind
of cultural theme
to it, which helped, I think,
unify our game in the end.
And, as Rachel also said, we had
semi-frequent meetings, mostly
at the end of the weeks,
just to catch up and see
how everybody was
doing on their parts,
and what we were planning
on doing for the next week.
And it also served
as a good time for us
to really sit down and
get some work done,
whether it's drawing some new
assets, coding a new minigame.
And having most of the people
there together at the same time
allowed us to really
bounce ideas off each other
when we were implementing
this, which made
things a lot more efficient.
And lastly, we realize
that at the beginning,
we had probably more
than we could take on
over this eight-week period.
So we did a good job of
cutting features early.
And the main one we did was
cutting the fourth minigame out
of our game entirely,
so that we could really
focus on making the three
minigames that we have
currently really robust and
really relevant to the ideas
we were trying to convey.
RACHEL WANG: So moving forward
from this where hopefully we
would be able to find more
of our target audience,
our focus tests helped
a lot whether it
was speaking to Pablo, other MIT
students, people in the class.
They gave us a lot of good
feedback about the game.
But obviously we
didn't get a chance
to speak with Ghanaian kids,
which is our target audience.
And that could definitely
help if we had a longer period
and were able to find
even kids ages 8 to 13.
In terms of iteration,
I think we could still
focus a bit more on
balancing the difficulty.
And then we mitigated
that by doing things
like what Justin said about
changing the text dialogue,
and also providing a lot of
help tutorials or instructions
throughout the game.
But that's something we
could always think about,
so that even kids younger
than our target audience
could access the game.
And then, obviously,
just making sure
the game is culturally relevant,
thinking about word choices,
thinking about assets, something
we could always improve on.
And then, finally, to actually
keep moving forward we
could implement
another minigame,
find out other
things about cholera
we really want to get across,
and add other adventures
to the game.
But the game right now is
pretty contained, and gives,
we think, three valuable
lessons about cholera,
and three very concrete
preventative actions
that you can take,
and bring back
to your village and your family.
So I guess that's what
we would think about
if we were going to go for it.
And now, we'll
move into our demo.
So, I guess, if
there's any questions
first we can take those, or else
we'll be looking for a demo-er.
AUDIENCE: I have a
question regarding
how you used like the
structure of like having
the many minigames
inside of a big game.
I wonder like does that
help splitting the tasks up
among different
members in the team
and make the process better?
Or did that add more difficulty
to finish all the contents
and correctly tie them together?
RACHEL WANG: Yes, really, I
think the modularity really
helps, so the three of us took
the lead on one minigame each.
But then obviously
there were components
that cross all the
different minigames.
So, for example, our
other coder worked a lot
on the conversation
and dialogue UI that
shows up in all the minigames.
And additionally,
at the beginning
we did run into an
issue where we thought,
oh, really the game is
just three minigames.
So we worked to
come up with an idea
to tie everything together.
And that ended up being an
inventory clue kind of thing.
So you could go around town
looking for clues that you
needed to unlock the minigames.
So, for example, to play the
water collection game you
need a bowl to
collect the water.
So you would go
around town and find
someone-- maybe someone was like
wearing a bucket on their head.
And you'd be able to collect
that bucket from them
and then play the game.
So, in that sense, we
were able to come up
with this idea that
could tie together
all the different minigames.
Does that answer your question?
AUDIENCE: Is its mother a cat?
LIZ RITA: Yes, [? Bunnykins' ?]
mother is a cat.
AUDIENCE: All right. [INAUDIBLE]
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: So, you cut
the minigame number four?
JUSTIN MARTINEZ: Yes.
AUDIENCE: About when in the
project did you do that?
And about how much
work had you actually
put in to that minigame before
you decided not to complete it?
JUSTIN MARTINEZ: That
game did not make it
past the paper prototype.
After we did the
paper prototype,
we realized that, that
game and the symptoms game
were actually very similar.
And so we [? introduced ?] some
or the storytelling aspects
into the doctor
minigame that we pulled
from the fourth minigame.
PROFESSOR 1: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[INAUDIBLE] will volunteer.
Thank you.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: I sure helped!
From our previous
discussion, I wonder
if I can take his bucket.
LIZ RITA: [INAUDIBLE]
like, go closer.
AUDIENCE: Oh, gosh.
I don't know if [? Korku's ?]
is going to get that bucket.
Maybe I'll keep it.
Wow, I already have two quests.
[LAUGHTER]
Never play with
fire by yourself.
[LAUGHTER]
Whoa, look it's
turned into a cat.
[LAUGHTER]
Ah, cool.
I mean, if I say no, I should
come back later, don't I?
[LAUGHTER]
Thank the bowl, and click
me when you're done.
All right.
Well, I know where to go,
but we'll do this anyway.
There's no water there!
I guess that makes sense.
If there was water in the house,
I wouldn't need the bucket.
I do all the wrong things first.
It looks like there are a
lot of bacteria in the lake.
I have really good eyes.
[LAUGHTER]
You-- I don't want rusty water.
Oh, the bathroom, that's a
great place to get water.
I won't go there.
Yay!
I have water.
Can I go swimming?
Yes, yes, I can.
I forget what you wanted.
What did you want again?
Paper.
I know-- no, I don't actually.
Oh, I guess I do know something.
Ah ha!
[LAUGHTER]
I guess I need to go
in the houses now.
That's my guess.
Oh, cool.
You-- I better boil that.
RACHEL WANG: You might want
to start the game first.
AUDIENCE: Oh, start the game.
I'll do that first.
I like this water.
This is great.
I just know that the well is
good, because I was just there.
Pump and clear, well, rust
was the problem before,
so where am I getting this
hot water from the pump?
Discolored.
Well, I am going to
be safe, because I
don't have to gather firewood.
I'm running out of firewood.
Now I'm going to
be in trouble here.
We'll go for it.
It's from the pump,
how bad could it be?
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Is this
the rusty pump?
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Oh, right.
That's the bad stuff.
The well's the good stuff.
Oh, that's [INAUDIBLE] pump.
Ah, whatever.
AUDIENCE: It is the
cholera that you've got
to test in this game, right?
AUDIENCE: Hm, I only
have three firewood.
Let's just do this.
One of the next one
will be clear, I'm sure.
Well and clear.
There we go.
We'll boil the rest to be safe.
All right.
Throwing up and have
diarrhea and very thirsty.
Oh.
So in other words,
you've seen the monster.
You should go see the
doctor, because you
have all those symptoms.
All right.
Where are my check marks?
Oh, look I got three clues.
Is that good enough?
Let's go out to mayor.
I don't have any more spaces for
clues, it must be good enough.
Nope.
LIZ RITA: [INAUDIBLE]
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Yay!
LIZ RITA: I just jumped
over that office.
AUDIENCE: I guess the
repetition's not a bad thing,
is it, for your demographic?
That's good.
[LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR 1: That's it.
Thank you.
RACHEL WANG: I think that's
it, that's all we have.
Are there any last questions?
PROFESSOR 2: I actually do have
one question about the music.
Because you have
it on the credits.
Is this like a piece that
the person wrote for you?
Or is this something that you
downloaded from the website?
RACHEL WANG: We downloaded it.
PROFESSOR 2: You might just
want to check their website
to see exactly how they want
to be credited. [INAUDIBLE]
title of the song they want
used, or something like that.
But if you've already
done that, that's good.
PROFESSOR 1: Great.
Thank you.
RACHEL WANG: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
PROFESSOR 1: All right.
We're done!
Thank you so much.
[APPLAUSE]
We really enjoy teaching
this class every year.
We really hope you got a
good experience for it.
I liked seeing a lot
of the presentations,
and I liked the changes that we
saw from rehearsals to today.
So there was a lot of really
good information in there,
both in the games and
in the presentations.
Again, if you have any
questions about future classes--
we don't actually offer a
game design degree at MIT,
but we do have a concentration
of comparative media studies.
If you take any
four CMS classes,
you get a concentration.
It can be from this list here.
There's information on your
desks about other things
you can do with games at MIT.
Course six students, if you're
interested in doing UAPs,
if you haven't
thought about that,
start thinking about that now.
We could help with
mentoring and advising
on UAP projects and
other kinds of research.
And I'd like to give a
thanks to the instructors,
Phillip, Sara, Andrew,
for all your help
with running the
class this year.
So, thanks again.
AUDIENCE: Thanks, Rick.
[APPLAUSE]